this is one of the most read stories on
our terminal this morning people are
clicking on it like mad on the website
because it's interesting how how
interesting that a site that is that is
based on keeping your information
private is getting hat what happened
here well they a shliach in has been
struggling for a long time to get some
love from the financial community they
disrespect they just want some respect
and they tried a few years ago to go
public in Toronto they had this sort of
complicated reverse merger thing planned
and at the eleventh hour a reporter in
Toronto showed one of the ads from their
sugar daddy sister site on Ashley
Madison to the head of the bank that was
backing this transaction and the bank
pulled out and this is sort of the story
of a she mad and like every time they
try and go legit they've been trying to
go public they want to raise money to
expand the fact that they have this
business that's actually really
distasteful to a lot of people yes makes
a lot of sort of senior financial
executives feel creeped out when they
have to go home and tell their wives
that they're doing this so so this is
really really damaging for them it's
gonna hurt them but at the same time the
bankers keep flocking to them because
they make money this company is
profitable yes they have experienced
huge user growth and their revenues
according to the company it's hard to
know for sure that there but they're
they're public numbers that they've
released suggests that they have
quadrupled in the last few years and you
know so it's a dramatic growth curve
however there is this huge stigma and
the fact is that anonymity is really the
product they were selling I mean they
are basically almost enticing people to
go out and do things that are
potentially life destroying yeah you the
reason their argument is oh don't have
an affair with someone in your office or
someone in your social circle because
your wife your banjo stage will probably
find out will help your branch out
exactly so so here they can go fishing
in the open sea and no
no so so just I don't know if we so
what's the backstory here on this
hacking so this is a group right what
does it call impact something well we're
still learning a little bit about what
their motivations were but okay but they
have basically said that they objects to
the fact that even after you delete your
profile from Ashley Madison like you
decide you're gonna go legit you delete
your whole profile off the site the
information so that the information is
still there but of course that's that's
true everywhere we've learned that a
delete is not a delete it exists
somewhere so so they don't want money
they just want this whole site taking
down that's what they have said so far
and I think it's sort of interesting it
really underscores the fact that
actually nothing that you do online is
actually private I mean it is all sort
of out there for the taking anyone can
hire a Russian four hundred dollars to
go in and hack into your email account
so hopefully this will be a cautionary
tale for people interesting you would
have to let us know what the CEO says
next about how the company proceed
definitely now that's not listening
anymore yeah it's it's a rough piece of
news